Me perguntaram no Instagram: "Vitamina E
é relevante para tratar doenças
hepáticas?" E vou responder essa
pergunta da maneira que seja mais
aproveitável para o maior número
possível de pessoas. Olha, hoje eu vou
te contar uma história que pouquíssima
gente sabe e que pode estar impedindo
você de reverter um problema que afeta
quase uma em cada três pessoas. Sabe
aquele ultrassom que mostrou gordura no
fígado? Aquela esteatose que o médico
falou para você? Dá uma emagrecida e
pronto. Pois é, existe um truque
simples, barato até que tem o poder
desinflamar e regenerar o seu fígado,
mas tem um detalhe crucial que se você
errar vai estar jogando dinheiro no lixo
e continuando com fígado inflamado.
Deixa te explicar direitinho. Fígado
gorduroso ou esteatose hepática não é
frescura, não. é um processo silencioso
que pode progredir pra cirrose,
insuficiência hepática e até câncer de
fígado. E o pior, você pode estar
caminhando para isso sem sentir
absolutamente nada, sem dor, sem
sintoma. Quando aparece sintoma, meu
amigo, já complicou. E sabe o que que a
medicina convencional te oferece? Faça
dieta e exercício, tá beleza? Isso é
importante sim, mas eu vou te contar um
segredo. Existe uma intervenção
bioquímica específica que atua direto na
oxidação hepática, reduz a inflamação do
fígado e pasmem. Tem estudos com
centenas de pacientes comprovando a
eficácia. Eu estou falando da vitamina
E. Mas calma, antes de você sair
correndo na farmácia, eu preciso te
alertar sobre o erro fatal que 97% das
pessoas cometem. Escuta aqui com
atenção, porque é nesse detalhe que mora
toda a diferença entre sucesso e
fracasso. A vitamina E não é toda igual.
Na verdade, ela é uma família de oito
moléculas diferentes, como se fossem
primos. Tem quatro tocoferóis e quatro
tocotrienois. E cada um desses membros
da família tem um super poder único.
Quando você pega aquela caixinha
baratinha de vitamina E na farmácia, na
grande maioria das vezes está levando
para casa a forma sintética, que é o DL
alfa tocoferol. Essa letrinha L
minúscula faz toda a diferença. E sabe
por quê? Porque a versão sintética é
produzida a partir de derivados de
petróleo e contém oito esteroisômeros
diferentes. Traduzindo pro português
claro, são oito moléculas parecidas, mas
não são iguais. Apenas uma delas, cerca
de 12%, é idêntica à forma natural. As
outros sete tem uma potência que varia
de 21 a 90% da vitamina E natural. É
tipo você comprar um remédio, descobrir
que só 12% dele realmente funciona como
deveria. Agora vem a parte boa, é aqui
onde a coisa fica interessante. A
vitamina E natural, que na embalagem
você identifica como D alfa tocoferol
sem aquele L, é a mesma molécula que seu
corpo foi projetado para usar. É uma
única molécula chamada tecnicamente de
RR alfa tocoferol. Estudos mostram que
ela tem aproximadamente o dobro de
biodisponibilidade
da sintética. Isso significa que ela é
absorvida melhor, fica mais tempo nos
seus tecidos e é eliminada mais devagar.
Seu fígado agradece, mas aqui vem o plot
twist, que pouca gente sabe, existe uma
forma de vitamina E ainda mais potente
pro fígado, que são os tocotrienoides.
Deixa eu te explicar a diferença de um
jeito simples. Os tocoferóis tem uma
cadeia lateral saturada, tipo uma
corrente sem dobras. Já os tocotrienois
tem uma cadeia com três ligações duplas,
o que os torna mais flexíveis.
E sabe o que que isso significa na
prática? Essa flexibilidade permite que
os tocotrenois penetrem muito melhor nos
tecidos com camadas de gordura saturada
como fígado. É tipo a diferença entre
uma chave reta e uma chave ajustável.
Tem um estudo recente 2022 que comparou
frente à frente delta tocotrianol contra
alfa tocoferol em 100 pacientes com
fígado gorduroso. E o resultado? Ambos
melhoraram a esteatose e o stresse
oxidativo de forma equivalente. Mas olha
a sacada, o delta tocou tririenol foi
significativamente mais potente reduzir
peso corporal, inflamação e morte
celular do fígado. E a dose era menor,
300 mg, duas vezes ao dia, de
tocotrenol, verso 800 unidades de
tocoferol, mais eficiente, mais potente
e dose menor. Deixe te mostrar o caminho
das pedras baseado na ciência de
verdade. Tem um estudo chamado Pivens,
que testou vitamina E em 247 adultos com
esteato hepatite não alcoólica, aquela
inflamação do fígado mais séria. Eles
usaram 800 unidades de alfa tocoferol
natural por 96 semanas, quase 2 anos.
Sabe o resultado? 43% dos pacientes
tiveram melhora significativa na
histologia do fígado. Isso não é
achismo, é biópsia hepática antes e
depois, mostrando a redução de gordura,
inflamação e até o balonamento dos
hepatócitos, aquela célula do fígado
inchada. E tem mais, vários estudos com
tocotrienois mostraram que dose de 200 a
600 mg
durante 12 a 48 semanas consegue reduzir
as enzimas hepáticas, melhorar o índice
de gordura hepática e até normalizar o
aspecto do fígado no ultrassom.
Um estudo com 71 pacientes usando 600 mg
de delta tocotrianol por apenas 12
semanas mostrou redução significativa de
TGO, TGP, proteína ser reativa e
marcadora de estresse oxidativo. E olha
que interessante, os pacientes perderam
em média 4,5 kg sem fazer dieta maluca,
apenas tomando o tocatoriano.
Agora vamos pro protocolo prático. Você
tem duas opções poderosas aqui. Primeira
opção, conseguir alfa tocoferol natural
na dose de 800 unidades por dia. Procure
no rótulo por d alfa tocoferol e de
preferência aquelas que vem com mix de
tocoferidis, porque aí você pega não só
o alfa, mas também o beta, o gama e o
delta. Cada um tem uma função
antioxidante específica. Segunda opção
que pode ser até mais interessante,
Delta Tocotrienol entre 300 e 600 mg por
dia, extraído no anato, né, que é o
nosso famoso urucum, que é uma semente
vermelha usada como corante natural. A
terceira opção, essa é a minha preferida
dentro da visão integrativa, é combinar
os dois, usar um mix de toco feroz ou
mix de toco trienois. é como montar um
time dos sonhos, cada jogador com a sua
especialidade. Os tocoferois fazem o
trabalho base de proteger membranas
celulares, enquanto os tocotrenóis
entram pesado na antiinflamação e na
penetração profunda no tecido hepático.
Tem estudos mostrando que essa
combinação tem efeito sinéstico, ou
seja, um potencializando o outro. Você
toma junto com uma refeição que tem a
gordura, porque a vitamina E é
liposolúvel,
precisa de gordura para ser absorvida
direito. E aqui vai um detalhe
importante, de tempo ao tempo. Os
estudos mostram que você precisa de pelo
menos 24 semanas, 6 meses para ver
mudança significativa na histologia do
fígado. Mas já com 30 dias você pode
repetir aqueles exames de sangue, TGO e
TGP, e começar a ver os números caindo.
É uma sensação incrível ver os seus
marcadores melhorando objetivamente.
Terceiro passo do protocolo: não
abandone o básico, corta o álcool, reduz
o açúcar, carboidrato refinado tem que
cortar, aumenta a proteína de qualidade
e gordura boa. A abordagem funcional não
é substituir o estilo de vida, é
potencializar com intervenções
bioquímicas precisas. É como ter um
carro potente, mas você ainda precisa
colocar combustível de qualidade e fazer
manutenção. Agora eu sei que algumas
pessoas vão perguntar: "Mas, doutor,
vitamina E em excesso não faz mal?"
Olha, os estudos de longo prazo mostram
que até 5500 unidades por dia de
tocoferol não aumentam a mortalidade
geral. A dose de 800 unidades está bem
dentro da faixa de segurança, mas é
verdade que alguns estudos levantaram
preocupações sobre o aumento discreto de
risco de AVC hemorrágico e uma possível
associação com câncer de próstata em
homens tomando altas doses por muitos
anos. Por isso, dentro da visão
integrativa, a gente sempre
individualiza, avalia risco, benefício e
monitora, não é sair tomando sem pensar.
E aqui vem uma vantagem dos tocotrenóis.
Eles não apresentaram esses mesmos
riscos nos estudos, provavelmente porque
a dose necessária é menor e o mecanismo
de ação é um pouco diferente. Além
disso, os tocotrenois têm um bônus
adicional, ajudam a reduzir colesterol
de forma natural, melhoram a circulação
cerebral e até tem propriedades
neuroprotetoras. É um pacote mais
completo. E aqui vai um pulo do gato,
que pouca gente fala, a fonte do
tocotrianol importa. Os melhores estudos
usar o tocotrienol de anato ou urucum ou
de óleo de palma vermelho. Urucum é
particularmente interessante porque tem
quase 100% de gama tocotrianol sem
praticamente nenhum alfa tocoferol. Isso
permite que você dose o tocoferol e o
tocotrianol separadamente, otimizando
cada um. Deixe de dar uma visão mais
ampla do que está acontecendo no nível
bioquímico. Seu fígado é uma usina
metabólica. Ele processa tudo que você
come, bebe e respira. Quando você
consome muito açúcar, muito carboidrato,
sua insulina fica alta, isso dispara um
processo chamado lipogênese de novo.
Traduzindo, o seu próprio fígado começa
a fabricar gordura a partir do açúcar.
Essa gordura acumulada gera inflamação,
radicais livres, estresse oxidativo. E é
que a vitamina E, tanto tocoferóois
quanto tocotrenoid, entra como extintor
de incêndio. Os tocoferóis agem
principalmente protegendo as membranas
celulares da oxidação. Eles se insere na
membrana e bloqueiam os radicais livres
antes que eles causem dano. Já os
tocotrenoides têm uma ação mais
profunda. Eles modulam a expressão
gênica, reduzem a síntese de colesterol
no próprio fígado, melhora a função
mitocondrial e até inibem certas enzimas
inflamatórias. É um ataque em múltiplas
frentes. Tem um estudo fascinante com
pacientes em lista de transplante de
fígado, doenças hepáticas em estágio
terminal.
Eles foram suplementados com tocotrenal
de palma no 200 mg duas vezes ao dia.
Quase 50% desses pacientes tiveram
redução do score MD, que é um índice
usado para avaliar a gravidade da doença
hepática. Isso é impressionante. Estamos
falando de gente com o fígado quase
parando e mesmo assim conseguiram
melhora mensurável.
Imagina o potencial em quem tem apenas
esteatose grau um ou dois. Mas veja bem,
isso não é mágica.
Não adianta você tomar tocotrenol e
continuar comendo bolo, refrigerante,
macarrão todo dia. A visão funcional
olha pra causa raiz. A vitamina E, seja
tocoferol ou tocotrenol, é uma
ferramenta poderosa, mas ela funciona
melhor dentro de um contexto de estilo
de vida otimizado. Doma bem, gerencie o
seu estresse, movimenta seu corpo, como
a comida de verdade. E sim, com a
vitamina E certa, na dose certa, você
cria um ambiente perfeito pro seu fígado
se regenerar.
Uma coisa que eu acho fascinante, a
cadeia insaturada dos tocotrenóis não é
apenas um detalhe químico, ela permite
que a molécula se mova mais livremente
pela membrana celular, cumprindo uma
área maior. Então, estudos mostram que
tocotrenois podem proteger até 50 vezes
mais moléculas de lipídio do que
tocoferóis. É como se fosse um
guarda-costas muito mais ágil e
eficiente. Agora pensa comigo, você já
viu algum médico no consultório te
explicar a diferença entre tocoferol e
tocotrienol? Provavelmente não. E sabe
por quê? Porque na faculdade de medicina
a gente aprende farmacologia, aprende a
prescrever remédio sintético, mas não
aprende nutrologia avançada, não aprende
bioquímica aplicada, não aprende sobre
as diferentes formas de nutrientes. É
uma lacuna enorme na formação médica. E
quem paga o pato é você que sai do
consultório sem informação que poderia
mudar sua saúde. Fígado gorduroso não é
sentença, não é destino inevitável. Com
as ferramentas certas, na dose certa, no
time certo, dá para reverter. Eu já vi
isso acontecer dezenas de vezes.
Paciente chega com esteatose grau dois,
grau três, enzimas lá em cima e seis
meses depois faz novo ultrassom e os
marcadores estão normalizando. A pessoa
sente mais energia, a barriga desincha,
a pele melhora, até a clareza mental
volta, porque quando você tira a carga
inflamatória do fígado, o corpo todo
responde.
Então, se você tem gordura no fígado, se
suas enzimas estão alteradas, se você
está naquele quadro de cí metabólico com
resistência ulínica, vale muito a pena
considerar esse protocolo. Mas lembra,
tem que ser a vitamina certa, D, alfa
tocoferol natural 800 unidades ou delta
tocotrenol 300 mais 600 mg uma
combinação dos dois por pelo menos 6
meses. E dentro de um contexto de
mudança real de estilo de vida, não tem
atalho, mas tem caminho. E esse caminho
está pavimentado com ciência sólida,
estudos robustos e evidências concretas.
E eu sempre digo, informação de
qualidade é poder. Quando você entende
os mecanismos, quando você sabe
exatamente o que comprar e como usar,
você deixa de ser refeito o sistema e
para ser protagonista da sua própria
saúde. E olha que coisa linda, tudo isso
está ao seu alcance. Não precisa de
receita médica especial, não é
tratamento caríssimo, é só ter o
conhecimento correto e aplicar com
consistência.
Para finalizar, deixa eu te dar um
conselho de ouro. Último conselho de
ouro. Quando for comprar sua vitamina E
e vire a embalagem, leia os
ingredientes. Se estiver escrito DL alfa
tocoferol, DL alfa tocoferil acetato,
qualquer coisa com DL, deixa na
prateleheira. Procura por D. alfa
tocoferol, rr alfa tocoferol, mixed
tocoferoids ou tocoferolis mistos ou
tocotrienol de anato ou mesmo urucum. Se
puder conseguir um suplemento que tenha
tanto tocofer quanto tocotrenóis, melhor
ainda. Essa escolha simples pode fazer
toda a diferença entre resultados
medíocres e resultados extraordinários.
Seu fígado merece o melhor e agora você
sabe exatamente o que que é o melhor.
Saia do vídeo agora se você gosta de
ficar no superficial. Eu vou te contar
uma verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
Conselho de Medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens,
omitir protocolos controversos. Na
comunidade fechada não tenho esse
filtro. Eu compartilho os exatos
protocolos que eu uso na minha clínica,
casos de reversão que parecem possíveis,
combinações off label que funcionam.
Fornecedores confiáveis, interpretação
avançada de exames. É basicamente ter
acesso ao meu cérebro médico sem
intermediários.
Temos live semanais respondendo
perguntas, PDF com 47 protocolos
exclusivos, o grupo no WhatsApp. Se você
quer visão funcional real, sem
simplificação para massas, clique em
seja membro. Não é para curiosos, é para
quem quer resultados. M.